and also you're not supposed to have a
girlfriend so you're like 35 um she is
loving but very strict she's constantly
moving constantly working constantly
offering you food I would say my mom is
wild she's very energetic and very silly
she can yell like a cross like a
football stadium they see Joanne what
have I done in my past life to deserve
this she'd be like huh
huh what did you say can you say that
again say that your mother I always
figured I would just like never day was
in high school or that if I was gonna do
it I have to do it like in secret behind
her back they want you to focus on
schoolwork and then by like 25 they're
like what's wrong with you Kevin if you
had a girlfriend you would tell me right
I'm just like yeah sure you don't need
any other man in your life besides your
father especially with my mom about
dating were basically non-existent when
I go shopping with her she'll be like
nothing past $10 my mom has basically
taught me that I don't have to pay
anything at full price I have a shirt
just like that [ __ ] why would you spend
any more money on another shirt like
that Kevin can you think about the
family's not just about you up until
college I work exclusively JCPenney
clothes with career my mom was just
always like are you sure you don't want
to be a nurse well you studied like
something English you could go to law
school when my mom met my roommate who
is a programmer she was like Chris could
have been a program or two he majored in
programming but you know he's not a
programmer you know you should get your
master's degree oh you know there's
still time to be a pharmacist doctor
still gets thrown around oh why don't
you like become a doctor she wanted me
to kind of grow in her footsteps and do
that same career but it never really
worked out and I think she just got over
after a while sometimes moms just have a
hard time accepting the fact that like
they can't help you with everything I
think that's also a really good
opportunity for you to like bond with
each other
I'd resented it when I was younger but I
appreciate it now and I wouldn't change
anything and so I don't think I could
ever thank her enough for always just
looking out for me and making sure that
had my head on straight had money in my
pocket and my stomach was full